was the night before christmas when all
through the house
not a creature was stirring not even a
[Music]
sorry about that guys here's a picture
of a puppy to cleanse our palates
well if you can believe it it's been 26
months since volume one of tim miller
and david fincher's love death and
robots came out and volume two has
hold on a second only eight episodes i'm
gonna die here
volume one had eighteen now you might be
asking yourself why this huge
discrepancy
well we know in volume 1 that netflix
actually shuffled the order of the
episodes for different viewers to see if
it would impact binge ability so while
your netflix may have started with akila
rift for example your friend timmy's may
have started with that one where topher
grace finds a society rapidly evolving
in his freezer
which is just like that simpsons episode
it's possible that the netflix algorithm
found out that 8 was the optimal amount
of episodes before people tuned out
hence that amount of stories for this
volume some have even speculated that
volume 2 was originally much larger but
to avoid the amount of time between
seasons they released these 8 with the
second half of volume 2 to be released
at a later date
we do know that a volume 3 has been
greenlit
in this video we'll be taking a deep
dive into all eight of these stories
explaining their endings easter eggs and
some of the details you may have missed
along the way
i've also left timestamps below so you
can fast forward to your favorite
entries
speaking of which let me know in the
comments below which entry was your
favorite so we can crown our best entry
for volume 2. and before we begin make
sure to like and subscribe
seriously 92 percent of you aren't
subscribed and it would be my christmas
wish from weird pants labyrinth santa if
you'd click that button
in no particular order here we go
starting with one of my personal
favorites is pop squad no not a deep
dive into your favorite pop band pop
here stands for population brought to
you by blur studios pop squad is one of
the studio's three
entries in this volume the other two
being lifehutch and the drowned giant
you know the one where you see a penis
in a circus tent briggs here is a member
of such a squad charged with hunting
down and eradicating children in an
effort to control the population
fun fact the voice actor who plays
briggs is also the voice of nathan drake
in the uncharted series
as well as the old pervert man in volume
1's the dump in the first scene we meet
ruth who is harboring two children these
aren't her kids she's helping out her
friends
perhaps that's why she's named ruth
which is derived from hebrew meaning
compassionate friend
names are important in pop squad briggs
comes from old english meaning bridge
his character walks the line between the
world of the privileged up top and the
impoverished below
he's a bridge between them alice comes
from old german meaning nobility and
just look at her living in the angel
tower an opulent nobility-like lifestyle
while the people below
suffer finally there is eve and i can't
help think this is a reference to adam
and eve eve being according to the book
of genesis the first woman
briggs is faced with a moral dilemma
deep down he knows what he's doing
is wrong for goodness sakes he kills an
innocent child
this child happens to be holding a
dinosaur plushie the irony here is that
dinosaurs are extinct and his job is to
basically exterminate children the
dinosaur thus becomes a haunting
reminder of his sins it becomes a
metaphor for the innocence of children
it's no wonder then that alice is later
called the slayer of dinosaurs that she
is complicit in this society of
oppression
in the more affluent upper stratas of
society literally the upper strata of
these skyscrapers briggs's partner alice
loves the immortal life she lives she
along with other members of society
undergo rejuve or rejuvenation
treatments which prolongs their lives
this is
in exchange for not having children so
not having kids seems a small price to
pay
for getting to live forever the problem
here is that this type of population
control doesn't seem to allow for any
upward mobility from those down below
well we can't keep letting people into
this
party it also seems that
marriage is forbidden in this world
briggs says he'd marry alice if he could
and as she's whisked away to the party
he looks down at his bloody hands
red also being the color of alice's
dress her makeup and nails both are
complicit in a society that commits
genocide both have blood on their hands
whether it be literally like briggs or
metaphorically like alice
briggs is almost shot by a father whose
children have been
killed he's completely unfazed by the
bullet that grazes his cheek and more
overwhelmed by the realization of the
death and cruelty his
job creates he'll later visit ipswich
collectibles where the dinosaur taken
from the little boy was purchased
another ipswich collectibles can be
found in the drowned
giant it's no wonder this shop is
referred to as collectibles since in
this world there are no need for toys
children are not supposed to exist the
owner says some of the toys here are
over 200 years old meaning that society
was structured like this for about that
long
and i don't know about you but total
blade runner vibes throughout this whole
story instead of hunting replicants
however briggs hunt's children and their
breeding parents
eventually briggs tracks down eve who he
saw purchasing a toy train
at the shop she is a small daughter and
he asks why she would want to risk her
life to have one
because i'm not so in love with myself
that i just want to live forever and
ever
eve has been alive for 218 years
she's seen everything there is to see
but now wants to truly live to see
things through the eyes of a child not
dead eyes like his perhaps that's why
the last shot we see of him is an
extreme close-up of his eyes
as he dies briggs lets eve and her
daughter live even after she attempts to
steal his gun
this is part of his character arc but
it's not truly completed until he takes
on the encapsulation of this oppressive
society through the character
of pentel the two engage in a shootout
briggs willing to sacrifice his own life
for the very thing he was sent to
destroy i like to think however that
this ending is one with a glimmer of
hope the story ends with some sunshine
breaking through hinting that the rain
will one day
stop a drastic juxtaposition to the
oppressive and dreary first shot of the
film
overall this was one of my favorite
additions to volume 2. not only did it
have fantastic visuals but a character
who had an emotional arc
and the story expressed universal themes
which transcend the genre
our second edition is ice and this one
has a lot of hidden stuff that's easy to
miss the story follows sedgwick a teen
from earth who has moved to this unnamed
ice planet with his family
although never fully explained in the
show sedgwick does not have any mods
modifications that allow individuals to
have enhanced strength speed and agility
this has caused some resentment between
him and his modded brother fletcher
every kid's mod is like you different
that's what the grown-ups say
but they mean better fun fact cedric and
fletcher come from old english words
meaning swordplace and bowmaker
cedric wants to prove himself to his
brother but deep down he wants to prove
himself to
well himself so he sneaks off with his
brother and his friends to do what teens
do and stir up some trouble with the
local frost whales
we also get a brief glimpse of the
rampant drug problem on this isolated
planet giving the title ice a double
meaning ice being a slang term for
crystal meth when sedge takes a hit from
this pipe here he
trips out but it's only when the teens
run from a pod of frost whales that
sedgwick is given the opportunity to
prove himself fletcher injures his leg
and his brother is the only one to save
him the other stronger teens
laughing as they rush past him it's
sedgwick the weakest of the bunch who
ultimately saves him but as we'll find
out in the next scene this is
all an act by fletcher fletcher goes
from limping on his leg to being
perfectly fine
this was his way of showing sedgwick
that he has it in him to be strong it
was only by faking his injury that he
could unlock his brother's true
potential
and show him that he isn't the weak
useless child that his father thinks he
is
it's also fitting that the animals
fletcher and cedric run from are
whales in the animal kingdom whales are
said to have some of the strongest
family bonds and this entire story
is ultimately about family and the
relationship between these two brothers
volume two's third offering is automated
customer service the one with those
really freaky elongated faces seriously
this
photo can't even capture her entire
visage i'm sorry i heard that word and
really wanted to use it we do however
get
adorable puppies this story takes place
in sunset city a fitting name
for its residents all elderly are in
their twilight years
this future sees a world where almost
everything is automated from
tennis matches beauty salons and yes
pooper scoopers
but along with that automation so too is
the customer support which our main
character jeannette calls after her
vacubot unlocks skynet in goes rogue
well it's actually called purge mode
sign me up one of the things i like
about this entry are the subtle ways it
sets up our characters
our friendly neighbor bill strokes his
phallic shaped gun as he watches
jeanette in some suggestive yoga poses
it's jeanette's yoga flexibility and
bill's gun which will later help her
defeat the vacubot but vacubot's defeat
alerts all the other electronics to drop
everything in pursuit of jeanette and
bill it's fitting that the last shot of
sunset city is of a sunset
there's also a fun little easter egg of
the sunset city meat department meat
department is the director
great name the shortest entry of the
bunch which also happens to be stop
motion animation is all through the
house
of course that being a line from poet
clement clarke moore's famous poem
a visit from saint nicholas which was
written in the 1800s
saint nicholas however isn't what you'd
expect when billy and leah creep down to
get a glimpse of jolly old saint nick
it's a terrifying creature which vomits
a presence
a fun easter egg here another classic
stop-motion christmas film plays on the
television in the background you know
those old school rank and bass christmas
specials
what i think is really cool here is that
this terrifying santa creature is
able to tell if the children are naughty
or nice and thank god they're on the
good list
i'd hate to see what happens if they
were naughty what would have happened
if we weren't good billy ends up getting
a sweet train set
and one of the things i wish love death
and robots did more was add more
connections between
all of these stories for example the
train here could have easily been a
replica of the one we'll see in the tall
grass
or that we see you've purchased at
ipswich collectibles in pop squad
speaking of the tall grass that's our
next entry and no it's not based on the
novella
in the tall grass by stephen king's son
joe hill
netflix did a feature-length movie on
this a while back which was the scariest
thing to happen in a farmer's field
since children of the corn
you just sit there seize him punish
him cut him down i command you those are
some mad joffrey vibes
this is laird our protagonist for this
nine minute journey he's reading the new
glasgow financial times which could
suggest this takes place in nova scotia
canada
the animation studio is after all based
in canada a particular note is this
article that reads west coast businesses
flourished amidst new worlds economic
growth it's a conscious choice by the
director to set this story during a time
in which the world is changing the steam
train symbolizing modernity a stark
contrast against the farmland of the old
world around it laird is likely a
wealthy businessman traveling west
his name comes from scottish for a
wealthy estate owner when the train
breaks down
laird's curiosity leads him into the
tall grass where he uncovers these blue
zombie-like creatures only to be saved
by the railway man who says this
isn't the first time it's happened he
doesn't know who or what these creatures
are but he imagines they were once
people
people who were left behind or perhaps
from another world
is the director trying to say something
about how changing times leave people
behind
or is it more simplistic like if a
railwayman tells you not to stray in
some creepy grass
don't do it we won't know for sure now i
wasn't able to get a copy of the short
story but if any of you have read it i'd
love to know in the comments below if it
offers any further clues
next up is lifehutch named after the
life support unit our character terence
played by and modeled after michael b
jordan
finds refuge in he has crash-landed on
an unknown planet after engaging in a
firefight with an
alien entity and i don't know if it's
just me but these things look a lot like
the coronavirus and considering the
whole story of lifehutch is surviving in
an enclosed space
it's completely possible this is an
allegory for the pandemic
an unknown entity has forced you to stay
indoors until you can get a vaccine and
are rescued yes i know those are
actually painkillers the majority of the
story however focuses on terrence
surviving a malfunctioning service droid
it's a grim reminder of our reliance on
machines
when push comes to shove we can only
rely on ourselves to get us out of these
life and death situations
this story ends with terence exploiting
the droid's weakness of attacking moving
objects kind of like how a cat chases a
laser beam he's able to use the droid's
own metal parts against itself putting
it down for good until rescue can arrive
although not the most
unique or compelling story the animation
here at times looks insanely realistic
and just goes to show you how
far we're coming with cgi perhaps one of
the most philosophical entries in volume
2 is blur studios the drowned giant
based off the short story by jg
ballard ballard was considered a new
wave science fiction writer who tried to
challenge traditional science fiction
conventions showing that the
genre can be more than just pulp comics
and alien rags they even name a butcher
shop after him near the end of the story
you might think our protagonist is the
narrator the scientist stephen but i'd
argue it's actually the giant itself the
narrator merely acts as a mouthpiece for
how the giant changes and affects the
people around it
what starts as a wondrous event filled
with mysteries surrounding this strange
occurrence
slowly devolves into one of sadness i
couldn't help but feel pity for the
giant as the townspeople began
desecrating its body defacing it with
graffiti throwing litter nearby using it
as a slide and chopping its body apart
later its meat will be boiled its skull
found by a nearby farm and eventually
will be forgotten the irony here is that
the giant starts off as a myth becomes
reality when it washes ashore only to
turn back into a myth as the people
forget about him the narrator remarks
how the giant's memory has
long since been forgotten and one of the
few remaining parts of him his
penis is the only thing left floating in
a circus tent mislabeled as that of a
whale's
don't you just hate it when your dick
gets compared to a whale's really this
story is about our own humanity we like
the giant eventually fade away and live
only in the memories of those who
continue on
the narrator ends the piece dreaming of
the giant's resurrection as he picks up
fragments of himself and journeys back
to the sea where he came from
he came from myth and so too ends in
myth for such a bleak story i did find
this ending to be
rather hopeful the narrator's outlook
was one of resurrection and returning
the giant to its godlike status
not the being that washed ashore which
the narrator and myself
pitied although this isn't a
conventional story i'm curious what you
guys thought of the drowned giant let me
know in the comments below
the last and one of my personal
favorites in volume 2 is snow in the
desert and i got a total mad max vibe
mixed with a little bit of star wars we
are on a sweltering desert planet with
these carrion-like creatures who have
stone-like wings to shield them from the
sun's scorching rays
wearing white and sporting white facial
hair is the aptly named snow who has
ventured into town to collect what we'll
later find out to be our strawberries
imported from earth a rare delicacy
as you can imagine water is in high
demand here these torture devices on the
outskirts of town show you what happens
to water thieves
snow only ventures into town about once
every month to collect his strawberries
and it's probably for the best since
he's a wanted man his bounty looks to be
about 15 million whatever form of
currency they use here this has been put
up by the merchant barris who will later
meet in the final
act not seen is this other wanted person
toxin who is of the octan race and i
love this because it's just fun
world building i'd argue that this world
more than any of the other so far in
love death and robots
is the one i'd most like to revisit at
the nearby starbucks snow orders a drink
and here's another great example of this
world building
drinks are so precious here that they
have their own safety lock which have to
be opened by the waiter
and it wouldn't be a sci-fi cantina
scene without a few bounty hunters
they've tracked snow down and are
looking to collect his balls
literally his balls have a gonadotropin
releasing hormone which is a real
hormone that
increases the production of sperm or ova
depending on your sex
snows have healing properties which
allow him to rejuvenate quickly
and grant him immortality he gets his
hand blown off in the bar shootout and
later says it will take
less than a week to regrow it's here he
meets herald who joins him on his
journey back home
they cool down in this tent during the
day under a refreshing mist to protect
them from the heat again
just another great bit of world building
herald tells snow that she actually
works for earth central intelligence she
wants to find him before the bounty
hunters do because whoever can decode
snow's reproductive ability can control
immortality in the wrong hands this
could destabilize what she calls the
protectorate snow makes an offhanded
remark pretty funny that he lost his
hand that earth is controlled by an ai
so he's not too excited about joining
her back to earth for snow
immortality is a curse he says that his
wife died 123 years ago she unlike him
grew old and he's been
on his own since perhaps why he so
easily hops into bed with hero well it
may have been centuries since he last
felt the touch of a human the irony here
is that herald
isn't a human when they're attacked by
bears men herald is shot and it's
revealed she's a synth well not a
hundred percent synth
years ago she was in an accident where
parts of her spinal cord nervous system
and brain
were salvaged and put into this
synthetic body she
like him tells him it's been a long time
since she touched another
herald's synthetic reveal gives us
insight into her motivation
of course she'd want to make sure snow's
healing properties aren't in the wrong
hands
if this rejuvenation power was around
when she had her accident it might have
prevented her from becoming
a synth so we kind of see what drives
her character the story ends with our
two characters embracing both accepting
each other's true selves the image fades
to white the color of snow and i'd like
to think he'll join her on her way back
to earth so those are all eight of love
death and robots volume 2 entries and i
want to know which ones you thought were
the best in the comments below
before you leave make sure to like and
subscribe it really helps the channel
out
and for more bad takes you can follow me
on twitter and instagram at think story
yt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much